Ramsey solutions John and Carol hey guys
how are ya hi welcome welcome good to
have you guys where are you from
eeny Rapids Michigan oh very cool love
it love it
what's that near Lansing oh what a mile
south of Lansing gotcha
that's a bit of a haul to Nashville yeah
a little bit y'all drive or fly
we drove okay and you're here to do your
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off one hundred and two thousand all
right very good and how long did that
take you 24 months oh and your range of
income during that two years we started
out one hundred and twenty one thousand
and and it had 171 Wow big jump in two
years what happened to that a lot over
time okay what do you do for a living
John I work for General Motors okay very
cool yeah you got the opportunity to
work and you took it I sure did
excellent Carol what do you do I work
for an insurance company
doing what I'm in leadership okay very
cool well good to have you guys so what
kind of debt was the hundred and two
thousand that you paid off the back of
it was our mortgage 102 was our mortgage
you paid off your house and we had very
small credit card debt
8 grand was a car and a little bit of
credit card debt all right very cool
what's this house worth about 220 oh man
how's it feel to walk out in the
backyard no it's yours
awesome yeah it's a good feeling yeah
that's pretty neat how long have you
guys been married 20 years this year
almost 20 years have you ever been dead
for a since you got married no never
never and now you are yep
and he living in a paid four quarter
million dollar house yeah making a
hundred and fifty seventy thousand a
year man that's incredible yeah well you
may not work all that overtime for it
but that's pretty incredible guys gosh I
mean you gotta be just in charge yeah it
feels pretty amazing we're just really
excited about planning our retirement
for the next ten years or someone just
getting into a good place for that so
we'll be uneasy this is a sliding
in-home now you got it you know this is
excellent so what happened twenty four
months ago that made you after twenty
years decided you were could and should
get out of that well I guess we got
tired of just spinning our wheels didn't
feel like we're getting any traction not
getting ahead we started thinking about
retirement coming and we started to
worry a little bit I guess a guy at work
was telling me about this Dave Ramsey
guy on the radio so kind of sounded
interesting so I started listening to it
and it inspired me I kept hearing all
these people you know calling in doing
their debt-free scream or you know
coming in like we are now well if they
can do that we can do that why can't we
do that yeah so you come home and you
say tell Carol after all these years
we're gonna buckle down and get serious
and clean this up what did you say Carol
okay I'm gonna be honest I'll tell you
what I said I said you want us to pay a
guy to tell us how to be with money but
I was hook line and sinker first-class I
mean so you went to FPU we went to a
view when we started the snowball and
paying off the small dad it was like you
said we got a raise it felt like we had
all this extra money and were able to
throw it at different things so it
really worked and following the steps
just showed that you can be successful
and do it you just need a clear path
that works and it keeps you really you
when you feel traction you can keep
going yeah you can you can if you
sacrifice you know feel traction if you
go the gym for two hours and work out
for a week and you gained four pounds
you're not gonna keep going right but if
you're losing some weight you're getting
into shape it makes it worth doing it
and the same things true with the debt
stuff here so way to go you guys and
Dave you've always you've always said
you know you got to pay a price to win
yeah man that's just exactly yeah I mean
you've had you 24 months of beans and
rice
yeah and you got your house paid for now
yeah very cool well we're so proud of
you it's got to feel great so what
advice do you give to people that are
listening they would like to do what
you've done they like to
dead free house and everything start
today and just stay focused and be
determined and be aggressive I mean you
have to be aggressive and on the same
page with each other the budget budget
the budget knowing you know what I each
other are doing with the money and I'm
just sacrificing a little bit that's
sometimes both you have to do to get to
where you want but yeah just staying
focused I think is the big thing now
your daughter is with you yeah what's
her name and age Marissa is she's 18
okay so did she suffer because of this
program she maybe did a little bit you
know I tidy bit not too much but a
little bit I'm pretty much hated by most
teenagers or they'll just tell you that
I love it fine well good job you guys
very well done we're gonna give you a
copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired which is oddly enough what
inspired you to do all this was to get
ready for retirement so that fits the
storyline so you've worked now you're
debt-free you've lived like no one else
now you're gonna be able to live and
give like no one else you can put
yourself in a position to win with money
and you have and to build some serious
wealth I mean you guys will be able to
do a lot in the next decade this is
gonna be amazing to watch so stay in
touch with us let us know when you
become millionaire yeah we will I love
it all right we'll give you that book I
think we've got some signed copies there
in the bookstore for you all right John
and Carol and Marissa Lansing Michigan
area a hundred and two thousand dollars
paid off in 24 months making one hundred
and twenty one to one hundred and
seventy one count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
good job good job good job good job I
love it very very very well done fun
stuff hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common